Britten's young royals are making their
first official joint appearance together
this morning so that's Prince Harry and
his fiancee Megan Markel along with
Prince William and his wife Kate they're
speaking at a forum for charities today
Roxana Saberi is outside London's very
snowy Kensington Palace with a highly
anticipated joint engagement all for
them together Roxana good morning good
morning this snowstorm didn't stop
Prince Harry and Megan from leaving
their cottage here on the palace grounds
to join Prince William and Kate across
town they're highlighting the work of
the royal foundation set up by the two
princes in 2011 to support their
Charities of choice after Megan marries
Harry in May she'll join their royal
highnesses as the Foundation's fourth
patron what will happen when the royal
trio becomes a royal quartet well Megan
says she'll bring issues like gender
equality to the table you'll often hear
people say well you're helping women
find their voices and I fundamentally
disagree with that because women don't
need to find a voice they have a voice
they need to feel empowered to use it
and people need to be encouraged to
listen the Foundation supports 14
charities tackling issues like mental
health and wildlife conservation but
before Megan can share the workload is
something else to take care of I guess
we wait a couple months and then we can
hit the ground running but up until then
like you said I mean you've been here
for your wedding first
of course everyone here is looking
forward to May 19th when the four will
officially become a family Alex
hopefully the weather will be a little
better than May 19th mark the calendar
Roxana Saberi in London thanks Roxana